I think that this particular problem
with Brian Williams is part of a larger
phenomenon in television news it's
become increasingly under siege from so
many alternatives first with cable news
alternatives and then with the internet
and mobile and that's put enormous
pressure on these organizations
unfortunately in my view the
organizations have responded by taking
their anchors and the reporters and
making them the story far too often it's
understandable it's a marketing decision
it's a branding decision but it's not
fundamentally what I believe journalists
should be doing I spent years working
with Peter Jennings and Peter believed
firmly and we all embrace the notion
that in the end we're not the story
we're reporting the story and as soon as
the journalist becomes the story you're
in trouble you have PR staffs and
marketing staffs who are coaxing who are
urging who are reinforcing any story
that makes their reporter or their
anchor appear larger than life I don't
know when we decided that reporters have
to be war heroes reporters don't fight
wars they report on wars and that as I
say is not unique to Brian and that is
not unique to NBC News and therefore I
am concerned about some of the other
news organizations who are so quick to
judge I can't predict what will happen
to Brian Williams in fact I don't think
there's anyone who could predict that
right now because I'm not sure anyone
knows what all the facts are the
starting point is to find out what the
facts are what I do anticipate based on
what I've heard so far is that NBC News
will need to find a way and I don't know
what that way is I wouldn't dare try to
tell them what the way is but they think
they need to find a way to send two
messages and this is the hard part is
you have to send both messages provided
Brian comes through this and based on
what I know right now I would expect him
to you have to reinforce that you still
believe in him that you so value him
that you value all of his years of
service service and the wonderful
journalism he's done
through the years number one and number
two no one is above the truth this is
the number one priority for any news
organization is to have their
credibility and their trustworthiness
and their relationship with the audience
and therefore they have to find some way
of planting a very big flag saying we
believe in Brian but we really take this
terribly seriously this is more
important than anything else we do